[音楽]
今年の3月までここ安城市にある農業高校に通っていました
農業高校には農業鑑定協議会という知識と日ノー競う
ちょっと不思議な大会があります
机の上に問題とフィンとなる食品や実験器具
植物の種などが置いてあって耳も20秒で磨いていきます
例えば
このような問題が出ます
このような問題も
わかりましたか
答えはどちらも a でした
この農業鑑定協議会という大会
僕たち農業高校生にとって
いわば甲子園のようなそんな大会です
僕はこの大会に出場して
日本一になりました
クラスメイトは
さすがやっぱりすごいねそんな言葉をかけてくれました
嬉しかったです
でもその言葉の裏には僕が日本一になって当然という意味が含まれている気がしたん
です
アナザからできたんでしょ私にはその才能が無いから無理って
だから僕はクラスメートにこう言いました
努力をしたから
努力をし続けたから慣れたんだよ
それができれば誰だって日本一になれるよ
もちろんこんなこと言ったらクラスメイトから大ブーイングです
それができれば苦労しないって努力できるのが才能なんだよ
皆さんも努力できるのは才能だと思いますか
僕はそうは思いません
努力するにはコツがあると思っています
目標を達成するとき例えば野球選手になりたい
周りの人の喜ぶ顔が見たい
他人から認められたいなど成功した時のキラキラしたイメージを考えて努力することが
まず思い浮かぶと思います
僕も前向きに努力する人だからできたと思われてきました
でも実は違います
僕の努力し続けるコツそれは
失敗を恐れる事です
僕にはどうしても日本一になりたい理由がありました
それは高校への進学を先生に猛反対された出来事がきっかけです
専門分野を学びたいから農業高校を選んだのに
君の学力なら進学校へ行くべきだ
後悔するから考えを変えなさいと言われたんです
その場はなんとか説得して進学を許されました
でも僕の選択が失敗ではなく成功だったと証明しないと先生たちの思う壺です
後で何を言われるかわかったもんじゃありません
だからそうならないために何か大きな功績を残して見返してやろうと思っていました
高校に入学した僕は新入生説明会で先ほどの大会があることを知ります
スポーツと違って農業高校のスタートラインはみんな一緒の一年生です
努力次第で誰だって日本一になります
先輩が前でこんなことを話して
日本一になるって凄い事だしこれなら見返せるかもしれないと思いました
3年生の時そのチャンスが訪れました
農業鑑定協議会の県大会で優勝して憧れの全国大会の切符を手にしたんです
本当ならばここは両手を挙げて喜ぶべきです
でも全国大会で日本一を取れる知識なんてまだなく不安でいっぱいでした
全国大会はただ知識を詰め込むだけでは通用しません
関連づけて覚えた広い知識を総動員させて20秒という短い時間で瞬発的に解く力が
入ります
でも大会まではあと3ヶ月しかありません
日本一になるには努力し続ける勉強し続ける努力が必要でした
とりあえず大会用の参考書作りを始めました
まとめる量は教科書が4冊で800ページ
俺がないようにこんな感じで終わったところには付箋を貼っていきました
でも
大会まであと3ヶ月の時点でやっと準備を始める人なんてなかなかいません
歴代の先輩の中には1年生のうちからコツコツと努力していた人もいるそうです
とにかくスタートが遅かった僕は11分1秒でも早くこの参考書づくり終わらせて勉強
に取り掛からないといけませんでした
だから空き時間は全部この参考書づくりに費やしたんです
そして1週間ちょっとでやっと完成しました
さあ勉強を始めよう
そう思った時にはもうやる気が燃え尽きていました
きっと普段のテスト勉強でさえも先延ばし先延ばしで前日になって行っ東危機感を覚え
て
詰め込むタイプの僕に1週間も集中して勉強することができなかったんです
完全にやる気が燃え尽きた僕は
やらなきゃとか時間がないからとか頭でわかっていてもなかなか勉強に取り込めません
でした
そんな日が続いている中ふと
もし日本一になれなかったらという不安が頭によぎりました
もしなれなかったら
高校で何も成し遂げられなくて3年間ただ
過ごしただけになってしまう
すると
あの時入学を反対してた人達が
やっぱり高校遊んじゃったとか
あの時言った通りにしたほうが良かったでしょとか言ってきて僕は何も言い返せなく
なってしまう
そんな悪夢のような未来が見えました
このままじゃヤバい
そんなことにはなりたくない
絶対に日本一にならないと
燃え尽きていたはずのやる気がメラメラと湧いてきて再び勉強ができるようになりまし
た
大会まであと2ヶ月を切った頃
友達に
夏休みも学校に来て勉強してたらしいじゃん
このまま日本一いけそうなのと聞かれました
だから僕はもう完璧このまま意見を余裕だねそう答えました
やる気が出てきて勉強が続くようになってちょっとだけ自信があったんです
でもよくよく考えてみるととんでもないことを言ってしまった時がつきました
だってもし日本一になれなかったら
余裕とか言ってたくせに日本一になれなかったねってからかわれてしまいます
教室では後ろから指を指されて笑われるかもしれません
馬鹿にされるかもしれません
卒業まで学校に通えなくなってしまいます
それはやばい
やっぱり勉強して日本一にならないと
この日からサボりたいなと思っても勉強が続くようになりました
大会までの間体育祭など楽しいイベントもたくさんありました
でも余韻に浸らずしっかりと切り替えていや
しっかりと失敗することを考えて勉強に励みました
そして迎えた大会当日
今度こそ本当に誰にも負けない自信がありました
悩んだ日々とそれを乗り越えて毎日頑張った実績を誇りに思って挑みました
結果はヒョン1
今度こそ両手を挙げて喜びました
でもその喜びと同市に
今までの人生でたいした努力をしてこなかった自分にとって
努力し続ける方法はこの方法が正解だったんだと確信することができました
ネガティブなことは考えない方がいい
ポジティブに考えたほうが物事はうまくいく
ネガティブな言葉なんてポジティブに変えてしまおう
これが一般的な考え方です
でも僕はネガティブな事を考えた事で勉強が続くようになって日本一が撮れました
目標が多いときや大きすぎるとき
今何をすればいいか分からなかったりコツコツと積み上げる努力がしんどくなったり
すると思います
そんな時は目標を達成する時のことを考えるんじゃなくて
逆に目標を達成できなかったときのことを考えて
そうならないための行動をとってみてください
一杯を考えて恐れる事で帰ってやる気が湧いてきます
失敗することを考えてそれを恐れる事
怖がること
これが僕の見つけた努力し続ける方法です
ありがとうございました
[拍手]